[Musica]
buonasera
un grazie all'associazione culturale il
palladio che mi ha chiamato ad
intervenire questa sera a parlare di un
argomento per me misterioso misterioso
fino a due anni e mezzo fa
fino a due anni e mezzo fa io mi
occupavo di nautica scrivo di barker di
regate scrivevo di tutti quelli che
erano dei movimenti che si avevano
sull'acqua ma con propulsione a vela o
propulsione a motore termico al limite a
remi la canoa ma conoscevo poco la
propulsione elettrica mi ero occupato
dalla propulsione elettrica per alcune
testate che si occupavano di green
economy
quindi la propulsione elettrica su
strada ma non avevo avevo poche
conoscenze sulla propulsione elettrica
su acqua e per una serie di coincidenze
che poi non sono i grandi che sono delle
vere e proprie coincidenze sono stato
chiamato a collaborare con la testata
vai elettrico fondata da molo tedeschini
che per dieci anni è stato direttore
della testata quattro ruote che è la
testata che si occupa della mobilità
termica su strada e ha avuto l'incarico
di occuparmi di sondare il fenomeno
della nautica elettrica e mi si è aperto
un mondo ho scoperto un mondo ed è un
futuro possibile
sì ma è già presente e neanche un futuro
anteriore
perché se andiamo a ricercare la storia
del della nautica già due secoli fa vi e
non delle barche che si muovevano così
come anche delle auto che si muovono con
sistema elettrico che per una serie di
motivi di motivazioni di ragioni
economiche culturali
oggi che non è andata avanti è stata
riscoperta oggi perché per
l'inquinamento perché speriamo nell'aria
pessima che ci fa male e fa morire
milioni di persone anche un bambino sa
che nelle grandi città soprattutto se
pensiamo all'italia nel bacino padano da
ottobre fino a marzo aprile ci sono
delle giornate in cui alcune categorie
di automobili non possono circolare e ci
sono quelle domeniche ecologiche in cui
tutti fermi e si gira in bici o con
altri mezzi non inquinanti a emissioni
zero a zero emissioni
ma nessuno sa anzi pochi sanno quanto
sia grande e l'inquinamento provocato
dalle navi tra le barche che hanno
motori molto più obsoleti le grandi navi
non cambiano il motore ogni dieci anni
il diportista difficilmente cambia la
barca ogni dieci anni hanno un ciclo di
vita
un'anagrafe molto più più lunga abbiamo
in circolazione abbiamo nei nostri porti
abbiamo in navigazione scusatemi delle
barche che hanno decenni di vita e
pensate che secondo uno studio
dell'agenzia degli stati uniti per la
protezione ambientale un motore
fuoribordo da cinque cavalli quel motore
che viene utilizzato dalle famiglie per
fare un giro al largo neanche tanto al
largo e per fare due tuffi inquina in
un'ora quanto 38 auto a 90 chilometri
orari per un'ora poter capire la
sproporzione il totale di navi da
crociere presente nel in europa inquina
quanto la flotta delle auto
quindi vi è un livello di inquinamento
altissimo se andiamo a
consultare i dossier il report di
legambiente vediamo che ci sono città
come venezia dove non ci sono auto
pochissime a venezia si respira peggio
che alla tangenziale di mestre che sulla
terra ferma quindi potete capire
l'impatto che hanno le imbarcazioni
sulla qualità dell'aria e non c'è
nessuna domenica ecologica perle per le
barche sicuramente lo avete mai sentito
di un fermo c'è il fermo pesca ma il
fermo motori marini 0 venezia e turismo
ci sono dalle 30 alle 40 mila
imbarcazioni questa è la stima non
abbiamo dei dati precisi fermare tutte
queste imbarcazioni che non sono in
movimento tutto in un unico giorno ma
sono comunque migliaia di imbarcazioni
presenti ogni giorno a venezia in
movimento sarebbe qualcosa di
particolare e di unico è successo è
successo due mesi fa ma è successo per
un piccolo canale vicino al centro
storico ei giornali locali più qualche
locale più naturalmente va elettrico e
hanno parlato ne hanno scritto si è
scritto
ma era un canale invece di città
bloccate in cui tutti devono tenere
l'auto in garage e cronaca quotidiana
fino all'euro 4 in alcune città
metropolitane per esempio bologna no
nella società molto inquinate invece
sulla nautica elettrica e sull'emergenza
ambientale creata dai fumi e delle
grandi navi ma anche delle piccole vi ho
fatto l'esempio del piccolo motore
fuoribordo sappiamo fuoco eppure
qualcosa si muove futuro anteriore
perché già più di un secolo fa vi era
una delle imbarcazioni che è uno dei
motori elettrici presente è un presente
ricco che ho scoperto in questi
due anni e mezzo con tantissimi
personaggi dei pionieri delle situazioni
molto particolari e ho scoperto per
esempio che nelle cascate del niagara
stanno sostituendo le barche che
accompagnano i turisti è una delle mete
turistiche tra le più importanti al
mondo
eppure anche la sono accorti hanno preso
coscienza e quindi trasformeranno
porteranno delle navi elettriche delle
imbarcazioni elettriche a visitare le
cascate parigi la senna 200 imbarcazioni
entro il 2024 vogliono fare il retrofit
che è un termine tecnico per indicare la
sostituzione del motore termico con uno
elettrico via il motore termico che si
alimenta con gli idrocarburi con i
derivati del petrolio e si sostituisce
con un motore elettrico
il moto elettrico quindi nelle 200
imbarcazioni dell'associazione che
gestisce questi battelli sulla senna ed
è un segnale per le olimpiadi green di
parigi nel 2026 nei fiordi nel nord
europa nei paesi scandinavi dal 2026
stop alle missioni stop alle barche che
emettono dei fumi solo delle barche dei
battelli elettrici queste proiezioni si
vuole fare così però in un parco della
croazia già un milione di visitatori
hanno visitato il parco fluviale della
croazia con un battello elettrico e non
solo elettrico che va con le batterie
alimentate da energia elettrica le
batterie accumulano e poi fanno
funzionare il motore ma anche con dei
pannelli solari che producono l'energia
perché il grande problema
il grande confronto a volte anche
strumentale con gli oppositori
della transizione all'era elettrica è
questa ma voi utilizzate dell'energia
elettrica ma da fonti fossili utilizzate
il petrolio utilizzate
il carbone quindi non è proprio una
transizione green pulita
invece ci sono queste barche in croazia
ma anche in altre situazioni
la possibilità di autoprodurre l'energia
quindi la la transizionale elettrico e
osteggiata e sta colata da coloro che
dicono voi utilizzate dell'energia che
frutto di metodi di produzione classici
cioè fossili quindi comunque l'emissione
di sostanze nocive per la salute del
pianeta c'è sempre però il mix di
energia è sempre più rinnovabile
quindi abbiamo sempre più energia
prodotta dal sole ed altre fonti di
energia rinnovabile è nella nautica
quando si hanno delle grandi superfici
questo non è possibile nelle auto
le altre sono piccole ma quando abbiamo
dei traghetti belli grandi possiamo
ricoprirli con dei pannelli solari che
ci permettono di avere una buona
produzione
naturalmente non possiamo avere delle
grandi velocità però ha delle piccole
velocità è possibile fare molte miglia
riuscire ad avere anche un autonomia di
8 10 ore
come succede in croazia come succede in
svizzera è come succede spesso anche in
austria e germania dove le nuove licenze
per le barche nei laghi sono solo
elettriche cioè in questi paesi è
vietato l'utilizzo di imbarcazioni
termiche e questo ha portato a uno
sviluppo anche dell'industria quindi
fondamentalmente è possibile sicuramente
nei laghi e nei fiumi
già oggi una transizione elettrica del
sistema di mobilità più difficile il
discorso nel mare dove abbiamo una forza
che ci contrasta però abbiamo tanti casi
di successo
greta greta è stata anche se se ne è
parlato poco è stata una testimonial
della navigazione elettrica è stata
imbarcata su malizia di una barca a vela
una barca a vela che è ricoperta da
pannelli solari che hanno permesso la
produzione di energia e quindi anche le
barche a vela hanno bisogno di un motore
in questo caso il motore termico è stato
sostituito da un motore elettrico quindi
fondamentalmente è possibile soprattutto
il problema principale della nautica
tradizionale è sono le emissioni nei
porti e come per le auto
se si eliminano i motori tradizionali
nei centri urbani dove sta il 70 per
cento della popolazione
diminuiscono i problemi sanitari
allo stesso modo nei porti eliminando la
motorizzazione tradizionale è possibile
eliminare il problema dell'inquinamento
ed è molto facile perché i motori spenti
in porto è un qualcosa che si può
ottenere già oggi è difficile fare la
traversata atlantica è difficile fare
una traversata da civitavecchia alla
sardegna con il motore elettrico è
possibile però spegnere i motori termici
azionare quelli elettrici avere zero
emissioni e quindi far respirare bene
tutte le città portuali italiane europee
e del mondo e quindi io spero che greta
è stato un testimonial ma ci sono
tantissimi altri testimonial che ci
dicono che è possibile passare da un po
dell'inquinamento ad un'età
dell'ecologia del buon vivere di una
migliore qualità della vita dove è
possibile anche evitare lo sversamento
in acqua le nostre bellissime acque sono
inquinate oltre che dalla plastica anche
dagli idrocarburi quel motore elettrico
questo problema si cancellerebbe sarebbe
eliminato e quindi se lab è auspicabile
questa transizione per respirare meglio
e per avere dei mari più puliti
[Musica]
[Applauso]